si la parole est à jacques myard merci
madame la présidente
ma question concerne le ministre de
l'agriculture et le ministre de budget
je vais cependant privilégier le
ministre du budget car c'est lui qui
mène la danse
même si c'est une danse macabre notion
ministre avez vous une politique des
jeux
aujourd'hui la filière hippique est en
crise et elle va dans le mur qu'ils du
bien sur al-arich économique dont vous
êtes le responsable crise due à la
concurrence déloyale de la française des
jeux avec ses jeux de grattage qui comme
chacun sait est élève le qi des français
qu'ils engendraient par le juridisme de
cette chaire commission de bruxelles qui
nous a obligés à appliquer un taux
majoré aux ventes des chevaux et qui a
réduit d'autant les propriétaires c'est
à dire les chevaux au départ donc la
baisse des paris hippiques
donc nous avons une baisse drastique des
paris hippiques qui sont passé de 850
millions à 800 millions les sociétés
mères sont désormais en déficit
structurel et surprise c'est dans cette
situation
monsieur le ministre que et dia sans
votre autorité de tutelle vous autoriser
un projet pharaonique à longchamp qui
fait que dans quelque temps pour faire
plaisir à madame hidalgo et bien les
sociétés dans deux en france galop sera
en cessation de paiement c'est ça la
réalité
alors monsieur le ministre cesser de
jouer les ponce pilate
vous êtes responsable de cette situation
quelles mesures allez vous prendre pour
faire des réformes structurelles avoir
une politique des jeux et permettent à
cette économie qui est au coeur de
l'aménagement du territoire de continuer
à prospérer avec 100000 emplois il y a
urgence
merci la parole est au secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget merci madame la
présidente monsieur député monsieur le
député mia cette question est trop
sérieuse pour justifier de formules à
l'emporte-pièce
elle est sérieuse pour deux raisons elle
est sérieuse pour deux raisons la
première c'est que derrière le pmu il y
à des filières et que ces filières
nourrissent certes l'aménagement du
territoire mais aussi des emplois et une
filière économique
elle est également sérieuse parce que la
question des jeux méritent d'être
contrôlé contrôler parce qu'il existe
des dérives sur la question des jeux le
blanchiment par exemple mais aussi des
comportements addictifs et c'est pour ça
que l'état entend exercer effectivement
ses responsabilités sur le secteur des
jeux
mais je vais répondre à votre question
précise concernant le pmu les jeux
évoluent vous l'avez dit avec certaines
formules un peu raccourcie mais
l'évolution des moeurs
le changement des générations montre une
évolution des jeux et donc probablement
un des ports je ne conteste pas des
enjeux sur la française des jeux pour
faire court et le pmu nous devons y
réfléchir et nous devons y travailler je
lui ai d'ailleurs évoqué avec vous dans
mon bureau il ya peu c'est filière
équestre devait se réformer l on fait
encore insuffisamment mais elles ont
fait des efforts sur la question des
retraites des personnels sur la question
des personnels sur les champs de courses
sur la question de ces télévisions qui
était très largement déficitaire elles
ont fait des efforts
elles ne sont pas au bout du chemin et
si nous avons avec stéphane le foll en
parfait accord
pardon autorisé l'opération de
rénovation d'hippodromes de longchamp
c'est parce nous appelle à nous
apparaissait à la fois nécessaire et
supportable
compte tenu des efforts qu'a fait la
filière
merci la parole